the agricultural council which will take place
today in order to find
solutions to the serious economic crisis
which is currently affecting the
agricultural sector with many the union has
reaffirmed its support for the
agricultural sector a sector which contributes and will
contribute in terms of
cohesion employment  social and sustainable development
in this respect the council took note with
satisfaction of the support party
presented by the commission which will
immediately make 500 million available
to farmers to invest at the same
stage of france two justices manitou
spots and cheeses